hello next week see you
in strasbourg for a new
plenary session of the european parliament delays
cancellations denied boarding how many
of us are actually complaining
against the airlines on tuesday a
report intended to stop the abuses will be
submitted to the votes of the deputies it plans
among other things, compensation in the event of
excessive delays during
intra-European flights
putting an end to the exploitation of seasonal workers in europe precariousness is still too often the rule for workers
from non-european countries living in
makeshift accommodation  seasonal
workers often work without a contract and
struggle to assert their rights on
Wednesday MEPs will vote on
common rules to guarantee a
minimum wage and decent housing
as well as a maximum length of stay
to avoid a new form
of slavery
regulate the markets  financial and
punish cheaters for so  Emerging from
the crisis on Tuesday MEPs will
vote on new rules
intended to prevent insider trading
and manipulation of
financial products Since 2003 common rules
exist at European level
but the weakness and heterogeneity
of the sanction regimes poses a problem for
MEPs propose the same
criminal sanctions for all to restore
investor confidence on
Tuesday former MEP and current
Italian President Giorgio Napolitano will
address MEPs in the hemicycle
his last visit to parliament was
in 2007 italy will take the lead  of the
rotating presidency of the
European Union next July and until
then have a good week